nous avons décidé de faire ce festival à
la suite de cette année de pratique
d'animation culturelle sur la chanson
avec un homme ayant à bourges et on
s'est rendu compte qu'il existait une
réalité dites marginales extrêmement
vivant de la chanson et que rien n'avait
été fait pour la mettre en évidence
cette chanson dites marginales n'a alors
pas sa place à la télé et à la radio
mais elle a un public et des raisons des
artistes comme la ville y est il vain
dick annegarn brigitte fontaine sont
alors rassemblés au sein de la même
agence dirigée par un certain daniel
colling j'ai eu l'idée un moment de me
dire mais si je veux promouvoir mes
artistes et surtout c'est cette espèce
d'identité de ces nouveaux artistes
ce serait peut-être bien de faire un
festival d'autant que ça n'existe pas et
que faire un festival alors à l'époque
j'avais un compère qui s'appelait
maurice frot puisqu'il nous a quittés
dupuis et maurice frot je me disais bon
faire un festival on va pas le faire à
paris parce qu'on va être noyé dans
toutes les activités parisiennes et il
vaut mieux aller en région
et comme je n'avais pas d'argent je me
suis dit ce serait peut-être bien de
s'adosser un établissement culturel qui
lui a plus de moyens de production et en
même temps peut amener une signature de
respectabilité
c'est donc la maison de la culture de
bourges qui va financer le projet mais
son directeur jean christophe de chico
se laisse convaincre par une équipe
hétéroclite composé d'écrivains comme
maurice fun de tourneur comme daniel
colling et d'artistes comme alain
meilland reste à baba on disait ponte a
three avignon pour le cinéma yakan et
nous on veut être ce que à la chanson à
chansons ce que cannes est au cinéma et
ce qu'elle vaut donc on était quand même
hein on mettait la barre très haut mais
comme on voulait pas dire qu'on était le
troisième mais le premier festival dans
le temps dans le calendrier on a dit on
va commencer dans les grands festivals
de printemps et d'été avec le premier
cette idée c'est mieux empruntant les
bourgeons les fleurs machin tout ça
c'est je crois que c'est jacques vassal
du rock'n folk et vive le printemps de
bourges et qui avait dit comme ça ça
ferait une référence au printemps de
prague que personne n'a retenu
d'ailleurs mais voilà c'est à dire qu'il
y avait en même temps un titre qui
disait la période le contenu le la ville
et d'une certaine façon le contenu un
peu engagé quoi un peu rebelle
il n'y aura plus de conneries à la radio
rien que des idées rien que du nouveau
connaissance et plaisir seront mêlés il
ya des speakers qu'ils vont changer de
métier on a beau fouiller et les quatre
horizons
rien n'est plus poétique que l'auto
gestion en 77 même philippe val qui
s'illustrera bien plus tard en patron
autoritaire de charrier 2 et france
inter
chante les vertus de l'autogestion j'ai
entraîné ce que vous pensez de la
chanson d'être le support d'une
contestation ou d'un message
pourquoi pas si c'est réussi la chanson
doit avant tout être réussie de qualité
si un message et de qualité d'accord
cette année là philippe val participe
aussi à la soirée hommage à charles
trenet venu en majesté pour adouber la
nouvelle scène ce soir je suis que
l'annonceur d'un poète qu'eugène du plus
profond de mon coeur
ne cherchez pas dans les pianos ce qu'il
n'ya pas soyez heureux d'avoir l'écho du
temps de papa l'acte de baptême dont je
dirais du printemps la première année 77
et le ceis l'intranet à ce que je sache
quand on avait dit il je n'ai entraîné
on avait tout dit et d'ailleurs c'est
c'est ce qui a mobilisé la presse
nationale c'est surtout la radio qui
assure la notoriété du premier printemps
claude villers animateur sur france
inter une émission très écoutée par les
jeunes installe son studio au coeur du
festival
dès le lendemain son public débarque
avec le sac à dos tu es venu
spécialement pour ce festival
ouais t'es pas de vous sûr de rien on
je vous vois rien du tout comment tu
trouves rien bah je sais pas je cherches
tu sais les pizzas culturel est derrière
toi en garde
à cette époque la jeunesse porte le
cheveu long et salle pons l'homme de la
rue l'arrivée de quelques beatnik et
baba cool représente un véritable choc
culturel
nos clients ne viennent plus complet ont
subi ces gens là ils sont bien gentils
mais c'est son fond désagréable il ya 1
10% qui sont fort désagréable et pour
nous commercialement c'est pas bon les
joueuses qui vous choque
1 l'exposition calé sur les marches de
la maison des cultures allez-y voir si
vous l'avez pris ou non mais franchement
pourquoi il était resté muet tous ces
gars ou filles ne rien se cotisait un
débat sur un projet qui sont vautrés
version les mains
dallaire
sur le plan de la population alors je
vais vous dire les choses se sont gagnés
d'année en année bon d'abord si vous
voulez le commerçant moyens qui ne
voyaient pas d'un bon oeil le festival
parce que ça le dérangeait pas ce que
beaucoup fermé aussi pendant fermer leur
store pendant le festival
s'il avait une fille de 17 ans et un
neveu de 20 ans comment vous dire le
conflit il était plus en direct avec le
festival mais avec sa propre fille et
son propre neveu
c'est un peu comme ça aussi qu'on a
gagné la population elle croit que tu
veux les voir et je la
et demain tu vas toute la ville jusqu'à
la fin du festival pouvait rien voir
d'autre
tu expliques tu vas tu donnes ton chéri
zinc
si les chais pas sensuelle comme
personnage des textes des chansons
beaucoup
on vend un art est là et s'il n'a pas
toujours compris le message de la
jeunesse le d'erudin s'est réconcilié
avec le festival qui propose une
programmation de plus en plus variés
dans les années 80 les stars nationales
et internationales occupe la scène
le printemps est devenu un rendez vous
incontournable y compris pour le
président mitterrand qui vient y
rencontrer la jeunesse cette course au
gigantisme coûte cher le printemps
affiche régulièrement des budgets en
déficit
mais depuis l'arrivée de jack lang au
ministère de la culture
il bénéficie du soutien de l'état c'est
eux mêmes qui nous en dit et notamment
le préfet de dire écoutez nous
la structure ne convient pas vous
progressé de 20 % le chiffre tous les
ans vous êtes dans une structure
commerciale quelques pas et donc on a
monté une petite sarl qui avait le
mérite de maîtriser c'est un outil voilà
technique juridique qui permettait
comment vous dire d'employer les gens
c'est une société mais d'avoir une
hiérarchie comment vous dire toute
simple avec disons le un responsable
gérant que j'étais et que j'étais le
patron c'est comme ça qu'on m'a surnommé
cette sarl moi on m'a demandé
bien entendu de prendre des parts mais
moi je n'ai pas voulu parce que encore
une fois ça fait pas partie prendre des
parts dans une wii et on tourne
c'est quand même on part du printemps de
prague et puis à un moment on vous dit
on créé une sarl et combien tu veux te
par un bon c'est pas ma culture m'excuse
employant un chat un chat le fait qu' un
patron d'une autorité directe sur son
personnel qui organise son festival
comme il le veut ça a beaucoup facilité
les choses
en quelques années daniel colling est
devenu l'unique patron du printemps mais
aussi des nombreuses filiales qu'ils y
sont rattachés tout en gardant ses
activités de tourneur et de managers
d'artistes comme jacques higelin son
influence s'accroît encore par jack lang
y confie une mission de réflexion sur un
nouveau concept de salle de spectacle
tout est lié
quand on a commencé le printemps c'est
ça ça lui a donné l'idée de faire les
élites par exemple
et puis il ya eu 80 bon l'avenue jack
lang et où puis de proposer une belle à
une salle comme le zénith au ministère
la culture donc son idée c'est lui et il
faut le dire donc et ça lui a permis
aussi d'ouvrir plein de portes des deux
billets pour le spectacle de vendredi au
zénith possible à paris et andreu neige
grésil non c'est vrai ça doit être un
oui oui prendront là-bas en 81 monsieur
collins planchent sur ce rapport à la
demande du ministère de la culture donc
il répond à une mission de service
public et il crée ensuite la première
salle qui est le zénith et il dépose la
marque zénith au nom de la société qu'il
crée avec son associé qui était
également en charge du rapport confié
par monsieur jacques lang donc là
directement à l'époque ce n'était pas
forcément une infraction pénale vu que
le délit d'ingérence d'or 1982 concerner
que les fonctionnaires publics
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
me choque l'avocat roland lineart et
rédacteur d'une lettre d'information
spécialisée sur le secteur culturel où
il est souvent question de conflit
d'intérêts à ce titre il s'est intéressé
à plusieurs reprises au cas daniel
colling
je pense que monsieur colline il a fait
comme il a pu 1 et donc il a utilisé les
pouvoirs qu'ils avaient les moyens qu'il
avait pour faire exister son projet
artistique
nonobstant toutes ces contraintes donc
on lui reproche des conflits d'intérêts
mais les conflits d'intérêts qu'on lui
reproche son pas excusable mais si je
devais plaidé pour lui pour le défendre
ses agents étaient attaqués je
démontrerai qu'il était contraint s'il
veut développer s'il veut pas se partir
à l'étranger
on est un petit peu obligés de se
conformer aux systèmes ambiant et donc
de rentrer dans les confine à terre
entre autres responsabilités multiples
daniel colling a aussi dirigé pendant
quelques années le centre national des
variétés un organisme chargé de
collecter puis de redistribuer une taxe
qui finance les événements culturels
le printemps de bourges en bénéficiaient
tout comme les autres grands festivals
daniel connaissait bien c'est vrai tout
ce milieu là et bien été avantageux
puisqu'ils pouvaient négocier les
cachent elles aussi voilà donc puisqu'il
pouvait pas les faire passer un projet
nitoo il faisait tourner un peu partout
le conflit d'intérêts d'abord nous comme
nous avions des subventions de l'état de
la ville du département
on rendait des comptes aussi aux gens
qui nous donnaient de l'argent public
par rapport à ça et donc il était facile
et ont montré patte blanche en disant
bon higelin il est vendu telles sommes
partout on le vend la même somme au
printemps voilà c'est aussi simple que
ça et que je n'avais pas moins intérêt à
à quoi faire avant de plus cher au moins
cher ouais je t'es content qu'ils
passent au printemps et donc il a il
avait un prix une valeur de 2 de vente
des festivals qui était celle là il
avait le mépris qu'ils ont en 1999 la
cour des comptes s'était intéressé à la
comptabilité du printemps on relevant
quelques anomalies qui concernait
notamment le système de retraite
avantageux que le festival avait accordé
à ses dirigeants malgré le déficit mais
quinze ans plus tard c'est une structure
en bonne santé financière que daniel
colling a revendu au groupe morgan qui
lui aussi est engagée dans des activités
multiples qui vont de l'organisation de
festivals comme les francofolies de la
rochelle à la production audiovisuelle
une que j'aime beaucoup anne pierre
desproges ça c'est dans